you say you would throw hands but
you did scream like a little [ __ ] so do
you want to catch these hate
we're about to catch these hands katie
come back to california come back coming
on saturday
baby guys let's celebrate we finally
lived together
and i want to make it insta-official my
lovely beautiful
bold ladies i cannot believe we are
entering the fifth
and final season of the bold type
you guys had quite a big break in
between season four and season five
because of this like little thing called
a global pandemic
were you able to have any influence on
where you wanted your characters
to end up at the end of the final season
katie kick us off i mean i think we
definitely i know we got picked up and
it was gonna be the last season
our show runner wendy striker hauser was
you know really lovely but when it was
like okay to travel
um we had a socially distanced lunch
outside and we kind of talked about
where you know she felt that jane went
where i felt that jane went
and i feel like jane's storyline and
especially where she ends up with such a
collaborative
experience in terms of you know ideas
that i had
and ideas that they had and kind of
melding the two together
to come up with her ending so it felt
like the right
way to end the show since it's been a
pretty collaborative
experience from the beginning so to end
it that way
felt right i think we owe it to this
generation of women to make them
feel heard well i think we were in a
really tricky spot because we lost two
episodes at the
end of season four because of covid so
and then we got picked up for season
five we only had six
to wrap it all up so the writers had a
really really
hard job harder than normal which is
already pretty hard
um to kind of figure out a way to get
everybody to a place that felt really
good
in that amount of time based on where we
had left off was
um pretty specific so but i always felt
very clear
about what i i i saw for sutton
and what i wanted for her and we
ultimately did get to a place where i
think um everybody felt
pretty pretty happy with where she ends
up and i really can't say anything more
than that because it's like
so i'll give it away in two seconds if i
even say
i'm so happy with how it ended like you
know so i'm not even gonna say that
aren't you mad if they're only helping a
certain type of woman what's the point
asia it was absolutely incredible seeing
your call to action
on instagram last summer and seeing you
kind of point out the the lack of
diversity both
on screen and behind the camera how you
were really feeling about cat's
storyline and season four and the
choices that the writers were having her
make
do you feel like since your call to
action and since you guys have come back
for
the fifth and final season was there
meaningful change
since you put that out there no i think
it's really hard and i
i can feel you know it's it's
been complicated to kind of come back
now and like speak about it i think i
naively thought like
just write this letter this was
originally like an internal
letter i'll write this letter and i'll
never have to talk about it again
it's like not um reality but it was um
something that was on my heart that i
felt like i just really needed to
share like it was almost like a
knee-jerk reaction i just was like i
can't keep this inside anymore
and as scary as it was and as much as
like my hands were sweating before
conference call about it i was terrified
i'm really
glad even though i'm sure there's some
people out there who may be upset
we have to have these messy
conversations because i think they lead
to
other conversations and they lead to
a new more nuanced conversation and then
eventually we can get changed but
um you know things don't change with an
instagram post and a phone call
it just doesn't work that way but i
think it's really beautiful to see how
both the studio and the network were
really willing to
kind of have the conversations and
support if they were
of the fact that i really wanted to
share it um not just with them but also
with the fans
it's been such a safe space specifically
for queer women of color you know
the fans of the show are really
important to me and i just wanted them
to know that i saw them
nobody knows their character is better
than all three of you ladies
you guys bring them to life and you have
spent so much time in their shoes
i'm curious to know if there are any
other storylines looking back on it
that you almost were like i wish we
could have handled that a little bit
differently
well i i know i sound like a broken
record but i've been waiting for one of
the girls to get their periods
and it's been five seasons i know free
for me
here people are listening like stop
talking about periods
but i really think it's an important
issue i think it's this like taboo topic
and it's a biological function that
doesn't justify
taboo yes
i've never heard you say taboo
oh my god i love that why is that so
funny to me well
you're saying it wrong anyway my point
is
it's a topic that we don't talk about
enough and
of all genders and it actually keeps
women in developing countries from
achieving all the things that they
should really be able to achieve
we have to talk about people who suffer
from homelessness
and we need to be providing like
sanitary like i am so
passionate about carrying it wait okay
i wish that the jane and pinstripe
storyline had been different like i
didn't like that it was just like oh he
just
cheated on her worse than we thought
because it just didn't feel something
authentic to
his character or the way that dan played
him like i wish that like
if they needed to break up that maybe
the break would have been like
we're at sutton and richard's wedding
and he doesn't
ever want to get married and he leaves
jane for that
i was always pitching that wait okay but
then jane get richard so
man you can't have
both all right it's my story well the
one with richard was really
tricky so i think that's probably the
only one where i'm i think like
and i'm still really proud of that story
and the way that we
we chose to tell it and everything and
like i said we got even deeper into that
in season
five i wish that i could just move on
with my life but
getting a richard is going to be a
process i was shocked
when they first told me that in the span
of five episodes i was getting married
having a miscarriage and then
getting a divorce like i sort of thought
we were going to live in the
happily ever after for a little bit
longer but it's tv baby people like
drama
apparently people on instagram really
love watching katie stevens
prank megan fahey oh you know who else
loves it
nobody it ruined my life
[Applause]
katie what inspired this and and did you
ever feel
bad about the torture you were putting
her through like take me
take me into your head i forgot never
felt bad about it
still listen i got her in on the fun
there is a video of us hiding in the
dark
me and meg are hiding in the dark and
asia walks into her own front door in
her apartment and we like
pop out of nowhere and she screams
and i think that megan got a taste for
just like how fun
and funny it is like i know i know that
it's like terrible to scare people
but like i they're good sports about it
like i wouldn't scare
somebody like i would be too scared to
scare melora and i was too scared to
scare asia for a little while but then
i had to throw hands i've had to
you say you would throw hands but
you did scream like a little [ __ ] so do
you want to catch these hate
we're about to catch these hands katie
come back to california come back coming
on saturday baby
get out get her out of here right now
i'm sorry i can stop you will stop that
was an empty promise
i guess rude if you could describe your
character's journey in these last six
episodes
in like one word or a few words what
would you say what
that's mine really what
that's a good one i think mine would be
mine would be um okay
it doesn't sound like it's gonna be that
good no what we should tell them they'll
make sure they know that it's gonna be a
great time
and it's definitely worth tuning in for
in spite of the
very lukewarm review that we all
just gave it well it's because i'm like
trying
like if i pick words
i will say that six episodes is very
hard yeah
we wrap up five seasons in six episodes
i think that the writers
did a great job of you know
tying up loose ends and also kind of
giving some openness at the end to allow
fans
to kind of come up with their own
conclusions of what could happen
afterwards but i feel like we
all are pretty happy with where our
characters end up
scarlett
[Music]